should a good director be open to
interpretation of a line of a character
from an actor's perspective
yeah absolutely i mean um the
collaboration
let's say um
is part of
i think where magic really can happen
and if i
if i am so stuck in my ways as a
director where this is it it has to be
this and only this i'm just going to
create so many problems for myself down
the road um
it might not be apparent but like you
know i do think that that the director's
role though of course is to guide
uh everybody towards a common vision
but
um but collaborating in a way where like
yeah let's say an actor
wants to do it this way
um
i'm always going to be open to that
conversation essentially i may
disagree or agree depending on what the
answer is or where this is going or at
least maybe this isn't the right time
for it but i see what you're saying
there's a 100 ways to
to kind of um invite that in so that
it's a safe space and people feel like
they're being heard and listened to
i think that for me
is um
one of the most important aspects of
directing in general is
to to be a collaborator
and if you tell people or you give the
impression that uh
that you're not there for that
then it can be very off-putting for
people that are working with you and and
working for you even
to try to get your vision told you know
what i mean
so
uh but that doesn't stop it at an actor
it stops i mean it doesn't stop with an
actor it applies to
any um crew member really i think in in
at the end of the day
and maybe it doesn't done
a hundred million dollar movie where
like yeah i don't want to hear
the uh like or like you know i'm
assuming that the pa that's there isn't
going to go up to the director with an
idea but but i have i've never worked on
that size
you know story and and i'm general and
in general i am of the opinion that if
somebody has an idea that's going to
make this movie better i want to hear it
too so
um
you know like it's exhausting too and
like some people have great ideas that
you never even think of because you're
so focused on
just getting the shot done or moving to
the next setup or whatever it is you
know
that stuff is important if people feel
like they can
be a part of the process
sure so if um
a character is so embodied in that actor
and they're just like you know what i'm
sorry thomas i just don't think that she
would do this in this scene i feel like
she would go here
you you would be open yeah i mean like
don't don't get me wrong i'm sure like
like that there's been times where
that's actually like difficult to hear
because you're like well [ __ ] i mean
like the whole
scene i now need to rethink how it's
gonna get shot and stuff like that but
at least you're solving it at that
moment as opposed to like seeing it in
the edit where uh
we're maybe like even more problematic
or you have to reshoot the scene you
know what i mean like
um yeah like sometimes you're you don't
have the freedom to do those things
either and you just need to get it done
and as long as everybody's under the
like you know that understanding too i
mean there may be a time
realistically where an actor says that
and i'm like i'm sorry we have to do
this way but can we find a way to to
make it a little bit more
comfortable for you as your character
like what can we do that simplifies how
to get uh to make our day i mean because
you have
the really the realities of of the
production that you have to deal with as
well
do you still recommend judith weston's
directing actors
you know i i
haven't read it in a long time
um but i do remember it being really
valuable to me when i was young
um
so i think so um
you know there's a lot of things that i
remember about it but also you know
again like i think that book and
actually any book that's related to
filmmaking is about providing
people
with a structure to begin their journey
into this um
you know a making a film or a short or
whatever
it's it's a way to help you understand
what the things are that you need to
think about at a certain point
it becomes less like i need to do it
like this book said and more like i'm
gonna do it my way
um because this is what works for me but
but i do think that all those things are
valuable especially for people who are
starting out for sure
how is directing documentary subjects
different than directing narrative
actors
or is it the same
it's um so different
uh that it's hard to
actually uh
tell you
how um i mean one is like
you're not directing doc subjects
that much i mean at least i wasn't and i
haven't in my experience
with zero gravity um one the the the
subjects are kids
uh which is another challenge in and of
itself
uh but
also they were already on a journey that
i didn't really want to get in the way
of and i also wanted their experience to
be genuine and i didn't want to
prevent them from having that experience
those were two things were very
important to me so um
so what i did most of the time is
film their day like in the class let's
say for the sake of zero gravity because
they're coding satellites aboard the
space station
and uh
and really try to use long lenses and
get out of their way so they kind of
forgot that we were around
uh we shot it as close like as
intimately as possible but that was one
way that we did it especially because
um because of kids and also you're
reacting constantly to what's happening
in front of you you're not setting up
shots really you're you're being in the
right place at the right time and you
have to anticipate often where that
right place and right time is going to
be
that was also maybe the the hardest part
especially in the big event sequences
which were like at nasa generally uh for
the film
we're like oh they're gonna have the
awards stuff here they're gonna be
looking at the screens here this is when
they play like i gotta be in the right
place to get
any of those kids uh on camera and what
their reaction is when those things
happen so i'm like we had a schedule
that was different than what the kids
had because we would have to be
you know
uh two minutes before them so that we
could make sure that we were where we
needed to be and things like that
um obviously
that's so different than
a narrative potentially where you're
scripting things and you're setting up
your shots and you're communicating with
the actors to give you your performances
and all those things
um i mean i think that there's some
value though in
adapting documentary approaches to
setting up scenes
in um narrative in particular
um we did set up some stuff in in
zero gravity for instance where it was
like okay this is what we want
we're in the kids home let's say with
their parents or something um and this
is what we want
to do basically
so you obviously are gonna set up
certain things like that especially in
the personal lives of it so they can
kind of convey
uh
more personal
um aspects of who they are and
and um and then they kind of run with it
but you're not really doing takes or
anything like that you're just sort of
going
and that
experience of doing that i think
i'm really excited to apply that to some
extent to how i set up certain scenes in
a narrative because i think that there
is a naturalness
happened
that was constant for the documentary
zero gravity in particular
as the director for it
that i just really am excited to see
how to apply that
in a narrative sense like sending like
paul greengrass is a really
uh one of my favorite directors because
of how he stages
uh
his sequences so that they're shot in a
way kind of like documentaries obviously
they're going to go in and get coverage
and things like that but like even in
like united 93 as an example where they
created that flight control room as a
and then ran it as like a two-hour setup
as i think is
uh how they they would do some of those
sequences just
to keep it constant and the the in
intensity like real that's fascinating
to me and doing the documentary stuff
and narrative like makes me think that
they can be linked but it doesn't
they're not ever gonna
you know you can't really just take one
and do the other either like there it
depends on the narrative of this of like
your script
in the in in a certain case and then a
documentary is like the story is going
to tell itself so you just have to
really prepare that you're in the right
place
and um ready i guess
did you see um framing john delorean
no because uh it was it was a mesh of
documentary and narrative
and so
you had um i think it was alec baldwin
playing john delorean and so he would
reenact certain scenes and then they
would also show him in the makeup chair
about to go into you know a scene and
how he would envision john delorean
doing these different things and then
you saw actual footage from news reports
and different things so it was it was a
great mesh yeah it was like a movie
within a movie and then they had all
these different documentary filmmakers
that had done movies on john
giving their commentary so it was just
this great mishmash oh that's
fascinating yeah yeah i mean like
documentaries are i mean you you know
there's so many different ways to do it
they can be experienced
experimental they can be archive based
entirely with with interviews and things
like that like i in my like uh both for
phenoms and and zero gravity we um
you know i opted for
a uh verite kind of approach like well i
want to be in the moment as much as
possible
uh but of course that's not
that that may be where it becomes
similar in a sense and what i meant um
talking about
uh where the where you can cross over in
the narrative sense just from my from my
experience but i can absolutely
recognize that anything is possible in
in
in either case really